we watched another episode of the show
before but it's time to check out
another episode of body bizarre let's
get started
56 year old fisherman and father of two
Alejandro Ramos goes by the name Willie
four years ago Willie suffered a
horrifying accident that mysteriously
transformed his body I kept swelling my
arms grew to an incredible size it
didn't go down he almost has the
phenotype the body type of someone who
who injects Synthol which is an
artificial oil it made to enlarge your
muscles but it's almost like not in his
muscles I was working at a depth of
around 115 feet a cargo ship was coming
it went over my air hose and cut my air
hose in two I knew I had to surface fast
I couldn't stay any longer I let go of
my lead belt and got pushed up like a
bullet I started to lose all of my
senses I opened my eyes everything was
blurry so the neurologic findings that
he's experiencing is basically a diverse
disease or Benz where basically nitrogen
bubbles part of the inert gases that you
inhale every time you take a breath
start bubbling up if you inhale those
gases at a depth of 100 feet those gases
are inhaled at a higher pressure
therefore when you go into a lower
pressure environment those gases start
bubbling up and imagine your blood
starting to Bubble it causes serious
problems usually in the neurologic
system and your joints Willy's chest and
arms ballooned leaving his torso swollen
and deformed this is a very very severe
form of it like usually it's mild and
usually it is treatable with a hundred
percent oxygen treatment usually in a
hyperbatic chamber using a hyperbaric
chamber doctors treat sufferers by
having them breathe oxygen in this
pressurized vessel I've seen patients
who've had sub-aquatic illnesses and
arrived completely swollen but with a
hyperbaric chamber these have
disappeared in one to three hours yes so
he must have had more severe damage to
his blood vessels as a result of that
that swelling where it seems to have
become permanent and you know when you
damage blood vessels and they become
more permeable they could start to leak
when those blood vessels start to leak
it can actually Create Edema in the
surrounding structures which is what he
could be having it's very similar to
what happens when you have age-related
gravity related swelling in your lower
extremities in your legs like you stand
all day you're age 60 your veins aren't
as spry anymore so they're a little bit
more swollen Blood starts to pull there
throughout the day and as a result they
become more permeable more edema comes
out and as a result you have thicker
ankles at the end of a long day which is
why we recommend to pick your ankles up
to wear supportive compression stockings
Etc et cetera Willie has had multiple
sessions in a hyperbaric chamber sadly
he has not returned to his normal size
as a result Dr aguado decided to draw
blood and take tissue samples from Willy
to solve the mystery I wonder what part
of the body he's actually taking samples
from is it from the blood vessel the
muscle the adipose fat tissue a month
later Dr aguado confirms that Willy's
condition was due to nitrogen being
lodged in his fatty tissue the next
medical step will be reconstructive in
cosmetic surgery to remove the fatty
deposits how in the world do they need
that test in order to say like oh get
cosmetic surgery and we'll fix it I'm
pretty sure that would have been
anyone's recommendation whether or not
they knew it was from the nitrogen
bubbles Juliana was born with congenital
melanocytic Nevis a rare genetic skin
condition that causes an overproduction
of skin pigmentation cells and it not
only produces melanin a lot it produces
melanin a lot in specific areas so as
you can tell it's not her entire skin
color it's just sporadic her birthmarks
and dark patches of skin also made
Juliana sad and self-conscious that's
very understandable if you're born and
you look different than everyone one
else around you especially as a child
it's easy to get bullied and then feel
like you're ostracized from your own
peers the uliana now posts photos of
herself on social media to promote
awareness of the issues faced by people
with skin conditions I think that's
great in order to highlight that humans
come in all different shapes sizes
colors and just because her appearance
outwardly looks different it shouldn't
stop her from living a full life and it
shouldn't stop you from interacting with
someone like this one out of 10 people
with congenital melanocytic Nevis will
develop skin cancer so basically when
you have a type of birthmark pop up like
that essentially you're having micro
mutations in those areas Because You're
Having excess production When You're
Having excess production that puts you
at higher risk for cancerous production
if I will stay at the Sun for a long
time every of my small birthmarks also
can change to melanoma and it's really
risk so that's why I need to go and
check them the way that we check them is
through a classification system known as
ABCDE each one represents a specific
criteria that we look at a asymmetry B
the borders C the color D the depth and
E is evolving basically how it changes
over time that's why if you ever have a
mole or or birthmark that has changed
that's a good reason for you to go see
the doctor and this allows us to
understand uh what risk each of those
birthmarks poses to the individual if
some of them are suspicious we do send
them through a biopsy to pathology to
figure out if they're cancerous Dr
witowski uses Cutting Edge digital
dermoscopy equipment to photograph all
of yuliana's birthmarks capturing their
exact positions and sizes so they can be
monitored for any changes in her
Condition it's a lot harder to gauge
changes because there are so many of
these birthmarks and also like look if I
have two small birthmarks on my legs and
one of them happens to change and we're
concerned we can easily take that small
biopsy but imagine she has many of them
if she can't like biopsy her entire skin
layer so for her it's best to do this
through a non-invasive method and be
strict with it like a camera this lesion
is the only one on your body but it is
different from the rest and it's a good
idea to remove the lesion just for your
own safety and then we'll assess it with
histopathology so histopathologies
they'll basically take a slice of it
look it under a microscope and then if
they do in fact see a cancer you might
have to go for excision with wider
margins when we say things like margins
what we're actually saying is that we
want to make sure that at the borders of
the area that you biopsied there is no
residual cancer which means that you got
the entire cancer back to the show in
just a second but first I want to talk
to you about PayPal honey the number one
shopping tool in America here's how it
works you know how when you watch a
YouTube video or listen to a podcast and
maybe catch wind of a promo code for a
website selling products you really love
but there are millions of YouTube videos
and podcasts including my own and you
can't possibly be expected to scour the
internet for all those codes every
single day that's where honey steps it
you see honey automatically searches for
promo codes so you don't have to Simply
shop the items you want and then when
it's time to check out let honey see
what promo codes they can scrounge up
for you it works on websites where you
already shop for products you already
buy like shoes video games food delivery
yum I'm constantly ordering stuff online
and with honey that process has never
been cheaper and easier the best part
it's free add honey to your browser Now
by visiting joinhoney.com Dr Mike
remember doctor is spelled out to start
saving on those orders all right let's
get back to the show jolison's
astonishing height of seven foot nine
makes him the tallest man in Brazil oh
wow three years ago jolison met Yvette
they weren't exactly a perfect match
even is just five feet tall maybe that
is a perfect match perfect match doesn't
mean they have to be the same height but
there was an instant attraction I'm
instantly attracted to that little goat
thing that they have is that a goat or a
puppy and the two were married within a
year I love that the cake Decor is true
to size at least true to proportion the
couple is concerned that jolison's
fertility has been affected by his
condition it's important to know that
before we start working people up for
infertility we do give a substantial
amount of time to try and conceive and
sometimes that's a year or even longer
gigantism is caused by a tumor in the
pituitary gland the part of the brain
that controls hormones by the time he
was 21 jolison had a range of other
health problems he decided to have
surgery to try to prevent the tumor from
causing further problems as he got older
I'm pretty sure Tony Robbins has the
same tumor and was recommended by
doctors to remove said tumor and decline
because he enjoyed the advantage that it
gave him and I'm not his doctor but I
saw an interview with him saying this
directly jolison will need to provide a
sample and
basically they're trying to look at the
number of sperm cells they're trying to
look at the sperm motility as well as
other factors to check if issues with
fertility stem from something within his
sex cells or is it his Partners your
spermogram test doesn't show the
presence of sperm the excessive amount
of hormones that triggers gigantism can
lead to a reduction in other hormones
such as testosterone this has led to
jolison having underdeveloped testicles
this should have also been elucidated on
the physical exam that should have been
part of all of this workup surprised
that it took them finding this out on a
test as opposed to a physical exam and I
wonder if this condition would be
correctable by giving him hormone
supplementation the couple is now making
plans to move forward with adoption to
complete their family oh that's not a
goat that's a puppy the whole time it
looked kind of goatee to me on the
outskirts of the city there's a boy
living with a unique condition 11 year
old Lee hang Lee hang now weighs more
than 300 pounds he suffers from a rare
genetic disorder called Prada Villas in
you know this is interesting because
this condition is not something I've
ever seen in my patients but it is
something that is frequently tested in
medical school and on medical boards
where it's a congenital syndrome where
it's a chromosomal issue more
specifically it not only affects hunger
but also cognitive impairment sleep
impairments many other factors in the
development throughout a child's life
there's no known cure for protervilli
syndrome which can also cause a number
of physical mental and behavioral
problems his large size would put him at
higher risk for development of early
onset even osteoarthritis joint disease
in a desperate attempt to help help him
lose weight Lee hang's parents are
taking him to a hospital that practices
traditional Chinese medicine designed to
help people battling obesity he has a
disorder in the feeding of satiety
centers in the hypothalamus located in
the brain this is true but it's a
genetic issue so it's at the core of his
cells the Medical Treatments here are
unorthodox but doctors are licensed
Medical Specialists and the hospital
claims a high rate of success we will
use traditional acupuncture fire therapy
and fire cupping this is where I kind of
start getting disconnected from the
adjunctive therapies like acupuncture
where we're talking about it for
musculoskeletal uses for pain uses where
there seem to be some evidence and then
we start moving it to just general
well-being or obscure cases like this
where you're saying that needles can
impact the neurological structure and
the genetic structure of someone's brain
that seems to be a little bit too far
out for me to say that it matches some
level of evidence-based medicine fire
therapy with Chinese medicine is where
we incorporate extracts of herbal
medicine that helps speed up metabolism
we light up the medicine with fire it is
especially helpful for patients with
abdominal obesity finally Lee hang is
given a round of fire cupping treatment
I don't even know what that fire therapy
is I'm not gonna lie it seems very
non-evidence-based and again cupping in
general has very weak evidence for it
but then for myofascial tightness for
restrictions again musculoskeletal
conditions I could see it being valuable
but for someone who has a hunger issue
from a genetic condition it seems a
little ridiculous to treat it with this
but the doctor points out that these
traditional remedies can only work if
Lee hang is able to stop his excessive
eating
if he stops his excessive eating he will
lose weight without those treatments
like that's the core of the situation so
I find it ridiculous that they're saying
that there's no foolproof scientific
evidence these procedures are effective
this is where patients in situations
like this are often misled because
they're just searching for any type of
cure where science doesn't have an
answer pseudoscience and misinformation
tends to thrive
Mark may appear healthy but he actually
suffers from one of the world's rarest
disorders why is he looking at the
waters so angrily I'm sure it has
something to do with water I have to
drink 20 liters water a day to stay
alive
I can last without water one and a half
up to two hours I wonder if this is a
form of diabetes insipidus where he
actually is either lacking or not
responding to a specific hormone that
prevents fluid loss excessive fluid loss
through your urine this is actually an
important hormone that your pituitary
gland stores in your hypothalamus
creates in order for you to be able to
balance the amount of water in your
system and that's a very tightly
controlled balance I will get very high
fever and dizziness can't can't remember
things and I do not know in an extreme
where I am and who I am it essentially
becomes a form of dehydration Mark
suffers from the rare disorder known as
renal diabetes insipidus or nephrogenic
diabetes insipidus the difference
between that and like the cranial
version of it is that the cranial
version is your body doesn't produce the
hormone and in renal or nephrogenic is
for some reason it's not responsive to
the hormone I wake up in the night and
then I go to the toilet and go back and
sleep again so you can can say okay
maybe it's 20 times a day it's important
that we point out this has nothing to do
with diabetes mellitus which is a sugar
control condition whereas this is a
water retention excretion condition or
water balance condition Mark's condition
is very interesting it's a very rare
condition unfortunately we do not have a
very good treatment for those patients
not to say we cannot cure it but we not
even have a reasonable treatment for
those patients so what can I do for you
today I love that The Scene goes from
him saying we have no reasonable
treatment we have no cure but what can I
do for you today my GP yeah and Billy
founta told me that
diuretics could be
useful for me I believe thiazide class
of diuretics can sometimes be useful
here diuretics normally treat high blood
pressure while not only high blood
pressure there are several indications
for what we use diuretics for Less salt
in the body could reduce the urge to
urinate
it's an experimental approach but Mark
has nothing to lose and there's
different classes of diuretics there's
like a Loop Diuretics which the most
common one that we we talk about is
Lasix thiazide type diuretics that are
more commonly used for blood pressure
control like chlorthalidone or
Hydrochlorothiazide after a few weeks
the diuretics seem to be working Mark
doesn't wake up in the night to go to
the bathroom quite as often he's less
tired and he has more energy to pursue a
very active lifestyle always great to
see some treatments working and I think
there's definitely progress to be made
in these conditions check out the
absolute worst medical takes on Twitter
worth reading Elon Musk is mentioned a
couple times this one huge thanks to
honey for sponsoring this video as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]